aftermath is a new expansion coming to
Mortal Kombat 11 and it adds new
characters story content and more here's
what you need to know yes you heard
right new story content is coming to MK
11 it's the first time a Mortal Kombat
game has gotten an expansion like this
which adds a new epilogue focusing on
fire god Liu Kang as he attempts to
create a new timeline after the events
of MK 11 he'll see some familiar faces
along the way including Shang Tsung who
was absent in the main story and added
later as a DLC fighter other characters
include the wind-god Fujian and a
four-armed half human half Dragon Shiva
who both joined the roster as playable
characters the third new fighter is none
other than Robocop and yes he will be
voiced by original actor Peter Weller so
you've got new characters joining the
fight but there are also some new stages
to fight in they're coming alongside
aftermath as a free update for all
players stages include the classic
Deadpool from mk2 and the soul chamber
from MK 3 complete with brutal stage
fatalities the update also includes the
return of friendships which are like
fatalities but not so mean your opponent
still suffers a nasty defeat but at
least the matches end on a lighter note
friendships new stages and stage
fatalities will be available to all MK
11 players you don't have to buy
aftermath to get them if you are looking
to purchase the expansion you have a few
options if you already own MK 11 the
aftermath upgrade will cost you 40 bucks
you can also get that bundled with the
previously released combat pack which
includes the six current DLC characters
450 if you don't own MK 11 you can get
the aftermath collection for 60 bucks
that includes the base game combat pack
and the aftermath expansion you'll
actually be able to jump right into the
game though you will have to wait for
the aftermath content like everyone else
the expansion launches on May 26th and
it's coming to ps4 Xbox one PC switch
and stadia stay tuned a game spot for a
closer look at the new characters headed
your way
[Music]
you